In about two months, we'll all be playing Sekiro, a game
that's really shaking the foundations of the soulsborn franchise.
And the hardest thing for this community to wrap its head around has been the lack of RPG elements.
Sekiro has no stat level up screen.
You're forced to use a katana and there are fewer gear choices.
But recently it has been revealed that Sekiro still has a surprising amount of character customization;
No, you can't dress up as an onion of the Deep or princess Lautrec,
but you can level up your character,
you can diversify your play style, and you can even spec into different combos and special attacks.
This is all done, for the first time, with something simply called experience; as you kill enemies
you'll rack up experience points, which
actually aren't lost upon death, unlike in other souls games.
Once you have enough you head back to the hub world, and then you invest them into three talent trees;
One of these trees is called Shinobi, another one is called Prosthetic and the third is called Samurai.
It reminds me a lot of World of Warcraft's old talent system.
You know, back when World of Warcraft didn't feel like a mobile game.
So just like this, actually, these talent trees will contain both active abilities that you can unlock and
also passive effects that you can invest in. So let's take the Shinobi talent tree,
for example; from what I understand this would enhance things like your critical strikes, your stealth,
basically everything assassin related. Take wall-jumping
for example.
This would be an example of a(n) active ability and an example of a passive Shinobi ability might be reducing your aggro range
during stealth, something like that. I'm sure you guys can think of more. Second, the Prosthetic talent tree;
This one's pretty self-explanatory.
An active ability in this tree might be unlocking combo attacks for your prosthetics,
like how flame vent can set your sword on fire or how your shuriken arm can follow up with a katana slash.
A passive effect in this tree would be
increasing the amount of shurikens thrown for example, as seen here, or maybe
reducing the amount of spirit emblems
you need to activate an attack. And third, the Samurai talent tree,
which I think will be my favorite, is likely going to focus on general combat;
so, in terms of active abilities,
we know already that there are special attacks that you can perform by holding down r1 and l1, like this cross slash attack
for example,
so I bet there will be tons of other varieties to unlock in this tree. An
example of a passive ability in this tree might be making you deal more posture damage, or
allowing your healing gourd to replenish more health. And apparently with enough experience
you can actually upgrade every talent in this tree and
100% complete your character, but it's unlikely that you'll be able to do this in a single playthrough. And
experience isn't the only form of currency; there's also gold, another static resource that we use to trade with vendors,
there's even apparently crafting materials that we can use to enhance our prosthetic arm. So, this is pretty great.
the more you explore the world the more enemies you fight and the more you enhance your character and
diversify your play style. You can lament the loss of a stat system all you like really, but you kind of have to admit,
grinding for a new attack or a new skill,
is a bit more exciting than grinding to upgrade one point of dexterity.
-not that I level Dex or anything- Leveling up is done at the hub location
which is called The Dilapidated Temple, a place located on the Ashina Outskirts and, like in other games,
NPCs will occasionally travel here for quests or for trading,
but we already know of three who will be there every time;
First, The Sculptor. As expected, he's the one we go to to upgrade our prosthetic arm with materials that we find throughout the world.
Second, there's going to be a woman there named Emma. She's responsible for
upgrading the amount of charges your healing gourd can contain,
upgraded with an item called spirit water drops. And third, and my favorite, The Immortal Soldier.
I love this. Basically, he's a swordsman that's incapable of dying
and so he serves as a sort of human training dummy who we can whale on and practice our moveset with. I
really hope he whinges is about it, like Crestfallen would. I have a feeling that'll be the same sort of character. And,
being able to practice combat here is
way way way more important in Sekiro than it has been in other souls games
because in Sekiro the hub will also be the place where we invest in skill trees and abilities that
fundamentally change the way our character plays, so it makes sense to be able to test these in a safe environment.
Outside of the talent tree, if you want a permanent upgrade to your health or posture, this is done through an item called Prayer Beads.
Apparently these are commonly dropped by mini bosses in Sekiro and
that's a good reason to fight these mini bosses instead of running past them, because yes running past things is
probably gonna be pretty
effective in this game. According to Miyazaki the environments are fairly open in the beginning
but he also said that they really open up around the halfway mark in the game, and
open up they should because not only can we grapple over things, we can swim.
That's right. No longer do we need to fear knee-deep water.
Imagine
sneaking into a castle via a water duct or fighting a boss that swims beneath you.
In Game Informer's two-hour session Sekiro explored the Hirata estates, and
the name Hirata should be familiar to some of you who watched this video;
Apparently we travel back to this place in a memory and this is accessed via the hub world which raises the question
by visiting this memory are we simply reliving something that has already happened, or
are we capable of going back in time to change the past, and,
considering we still have our ninja prosthetic in all of these scenes, I'm leaning towards the latter.
I think we might be able to change things here. The village is being razed to the ground
by drunken bandits. I can't wait to figure out why.
Second mini-boss of this stage is one of these drunken bandits. His name is Juzou
The Drunkard. In his second phase he spits poison onto his weapon
which means it will probably damage you if you try to parry him, and this is a cool example of how they can subvert the
core gameplay in Sekiro, because everyone's playing in a similar way,
so everyone is going to have to find a way around this, regardless of your built. Apparently during this mini boss
you can find a nearby NPC who will help you during this fight,
but since there's no summoning system in Sekiro, you know, there's no online, there's no Soapstones or anything,
reports say that if this NPC dies during the fight it might be permanent.
Not everyone is undead this time, you have to remember. And
the concept of death permanence in Sekiro, for NPCs at least
could mark a pretty huge departure from all of the years and years of undead
characters we've had with souls games; in those games
it was often difficult to pin down a canon death for the character but in Sekiro, with
well-defined death comes more emotional stories and, speaking of emotion,
apparently some of these NPCs now have their own soundtracks.
We've known for a while that the music is being composed by the legendary
Yuka Kitamura, who has done in-house music for many From games before this and
she's going to have her hands full because there's more music in this game than in any other previous title.
Not only is there the music for boss battles,
there is music during stealth, during combat, during exploration, and there are even songs created for specific
characters said to enhance the emotions associated with their stories, and
as someone who spends hours and hours finding the perfect music to suit these characters in "Prepare to Cry"
this last point makes me pretty excited.
Think how fitting Gwyn's theme is for his character and then apply that to some of your favourite characters in these games,
they kind of all deserve it.
All of this pales in comparison to,
perhaps the biggest news this week;
Sekiro has a pause button. I'll just let that sink in a bit.
It actually makes more sense in this game since Sekiro is about killing ingeniously,
you can apparently pause and get an opportunity to rifle through your equipment and your items for a solution to your problem.
The biggest curiosity that remains, I think, is the death penalty.
Miyazaki himself recently said that it's still taking shape, and it's very unique, and it's more personal than ever before, and
he also said that it's not just going to be the classic corpse run to retrieve your souls.
So what could it be? I want you guys to help me out with this one. I reckon together we'll probably stumble across it.
So here are my current ideas; First, since Miyazaki says that the death penalty for dying is more personal,
then I think perhaps it's our prince who is keeping us alive with his blood.
Our prince, after all, in the last trailer said "Wolf, along with my blood, you must live."
I wouldn't be surprised if with every death we weaken our prince. Or,
perhaps with every death we develop a more difficult world state, you know
just like world tendency in Demon Souls,
perhaps enemies grow stronger every time we die. Since we pray to these statues which are called demon Buddha statues,
what if Sekiro himself becomes more demon-like with every death? Imagine a sort of deal with the devil every time you die.
And finally, Bloodborne had an insight meter. What if our perception of the world changes negatively with every death?
These are some ideas.
Can you think of others? Let me know in the comments below and, if you're watching this video as it goes live right now,
chances are I'm streaming right now. So, come over to Twitch and say hi. I'll see you all next time.